South Korea is on high alert for a
possible threat coming across the border
from North Korea this time it's not a
military threat but a biological one in
the form of African swine fever and it
may be an impossible one to defend
against because of the 250 kilometer
long Demilitarized Zone that separates
the two countries from googan aid on
this honor we can control the spread of
the virus from other countries like
China at airports or seaports however we
have little information about North
Korea it's a relief that there is no
exchange of people or goods but even if
the South becomes free of the virus we
will always continue to have a big
headache the South Koreans aren't sure
where the virus came from but the first
case was reported in North Korea in May
intelligence reports suggest it's now
spread around much of the reclusive
country last month South Korea reported
its first case prompting the government
to begin culling pigs on farms in the
area vehicles coming and going from
places where the disease has been found
are being sprayed with chemicals to
prevent it spreading further proving
that the virus came across the border
from North Korea will be difficult if
not impossible obviously there is no
human or vehicle traffic through this
area but there is animal traffic and
last week the body of a dead wild boar
tested positive for the disease
elsewhere evidence of what South Korea
is trying to avoid China the world's
largest pork producer has seen almost
200 million pigs killed or culled and
its production is forecast to be down by
25% this year the virus has now been
found in around 50 countries and is
wiped out more than a quarter of the
world's pig population to help them
fight the outbreak the South Koreans
have been trying to get more information
from the north as we have mentioned
previously we have informed the north of
the outbreak of the ASF in the south and
also proposed to cooperate on quarantine
efforts but they've had no response in
the meantime they're intensifying their
battle against African swine fever but
they know there's nothing they can do
about what's going on in North Korea
Wayne hey al Jazeera Kang wha
Island South Korea